I do not see the point of inviting in
1975 to a country and then telling us
who we can have sex with
[Applause]
don't miss this amazing opportunity from
Nature's blends to get your finest
premium black seed oil and shilajit to
get that energy levels back up check
them out now
brothers and sisters and dear friends
the following video you're going to show
is going to disturb you this was a
concert done by in Malaysia by a group
called 1975 maybe we should send them
back to 1975. these individuals have no
shame and always I always tell people
the lgbtqt community seem all nice and
peaceful I have never seen anyone so
hostile more than the far right far
right these people out of their bloody
mind yes absolutely
foreign
it's crazy you are invited to a Muslim
country because I don't even know why
you're invited you are invited to a
Muslim country and there are sadly
Muslims who are attending this country
and then they get disappointed after
like he literally humiliated and they
deserved it like the prophet Muhammad
peaceful him said that the you guys the
Muslims are going to follow the
Christians and the Jews to every step
they take are left by on left until they
end the lizard's whole and they'll enter
a little soul you will do the same
meaning there is yeah you're going to do
everything we do because you have an
insecurity complex that's what is you
have insecurity complex and this is a
problem that Muslims face sadly
subhanallah watch this video and look
what he says in the concept not what
this deal does okay I do not see the
coin of inviting The 1975 to a country
and then telling us who we can have sex
with
what you guys just saw there imagine
going to a concert imagine me going to
the Western like like doing a concert in
a western uh world and I'm just shoving
my opinions down their throat and not
only that I'm doing an action AAA
protest oh actually whatever it may be
for that matter the Western World say
look how dare you come and disrespect
our country insult us then come here and
protest in that manner yes this
absolutely like imagine how vile you
must be and then act like you know they
would kick me out man they'll be there
this will be global news but it's okay
they go to a Muslim country go there and
promote LGBT we don't want your world
view what objective proof do you have
what moral compass are you using to
prove to us your way of life is better
than our way of life you are so damn
ignorant about the reality of the world
that you think you live in a little
bubble and everyone listen no they don't
majority of the world do not want to
live the way you guys live you don't
even know what a woman is you never know
what a woman is you've taken the woman's
rights by giving it to a man who can go
and enter the toilet as a man I live as
a man and God knows what when they are
locked up in prisons and what kind of
stuff happened my daughter goes into
those bathrooms and no man needs to be
in there you understand me oh man you
are a man so you are coming and doing
this and look at some of this Muslim
Malaysian Muslims sadly I'm not saying
all of them look at their reaction now
I'll take your money you can find me but
I've done this before and it doesn't
feel good
just sing the damn song
when you come here and then insult our
country
you see what you guys saw there well lie
that is a humiliation from Allah you are
there I don't know if she's wearing a
hijab or not yet okay she is there and
the guy is literally swearing at them
insulting their country and while Elijah
say something but don't you respect you
deserve that if I went to that concert
and they did that and they insulted me
no I'll say I'll say I deserved it if
they spot in my face I'll deserve it if
they slapped me in my face I said I
deserved it you know why for turning
your back on Allah and his messenger and
going to such places where there is
nothing but filth which you witness for
yourself okay the guy came there saying
oh you're not going to tell me this that
you're in a Muslim land who the hell do
you think you are to come and push your
agenda and you're tapped in the head
won't view down our throat we reject it
and we will fight it to the last breath
we have yes so my brothers and sisters
know that
um
the Quran came down and it honored us
and it is this guitar if we leave we
will be Dishonored and that's exactly
what we're seeing today Muslims in the
insecure to go into this concept you
have the Quran no music on this planet
Earth will ever match the Quran no music